Stevo's just eat up with Envy
go ahead
okay I'm gonna Push It Forward a little
it's been just over 20 years since the
premiere of MTV's jackass
self-proclaimed professional idiots
Stevo was one of its breakout Stars
since then he's survived his trademark
wild stunts along with some personal
struggles all detail in his second
Memoir coming out next week as our Jamie
wax found out while Stevo has made his
name by being outrageously juvenile
he's not a kid anymore
[Applause]
a situation that absolutely nobody ever
thought possible I'm Stevo in my 40s
that's right Stephen Stevo Glover one of
the most recognized people associated
with the hit TV and film series jackass
is in his 40s yeah I think this new book
is sort of
a new chapter literally in your
evolution
it is the Memoir is thoughtful and
revealing but on brand it's titled A
Hard kick in the nuts the idea of
confronting middle age is something that
I'm really actually wrestling with it's
almost uncomfortable for me the way my
audience stays so young
so I thought maybe uh it would be better
to kind of present it as a book of
wisdom the wisdom I've gleaned from a
lifetime of terrible decisions and kind
of package it in a way that's uh serious
and funny at the same time the new book
is filled with profound observations and
Frank Revelations if the first one went
to the bone this book goes to the marrow
all right I I love that I remember uh
feeling kind of like very exposed and
vulnerable and that's just how how it
should be I think you actually checked
in with friends like Johnny Knoxville I
did I I wanted him to be okay with it I
wanted him to be proud of me and um I
was terrified when he called after
reading it I just answered this call
thinking that he was about to say how
dare you'd show me in in this light he
said oh I never thought how dare you he
said there were a lot of times I thought
oh this doesn't sound good why is Stevo
sharing this and that that sort of uh
indicated level of self-awareness that
he was impressed by part of that
self-awareness was confronting various
addictions including his addiction to
attention I remember when I moved out to
Los Angeles in 2001.
Steve was dead and there's gonna be
trouble my answer to the question why do
I do what I do was
very simple because I want to be
remembered forever like at my core I am
an attention [ __ ] and that's it I'm not
a thrill seeker per se
I'm not an adrenaline junkie
oh
unless it gets you attention right no
I'm terrified of roller coasters
I swear to God something else that
terrified him was doing stand-up comedy
for the first time
that means the Xanax the grass or the
Birds but I feel [ __ ] correct
there's no crazier stunt than me getting
on that stage and trying to do jokes it
was terrifying it was scary then jumping
over and oh my God each comic would do
like 10 minutes and I sat there thinking
about like yo what am I gonna say and I
came up with one joke and I got a good
laugh I was uh
just not immediately addicted so before
leaving the comedy club that night I
scheduled my return did it a couple
times but I ended up really bombing
badly and 11 years of just Relentless
grinding on The Comedy Club Circuit I
managed to develop the craft and find my
voice and really put together a show
that um that people want to see so far
we've got three cats three dogs three
goats and four pissed off Neighbors
finding that voice took separating his
true self from the Persona he created on
jackass
everybody was telling me Oh well your
show is going to get canceled and then
you're going to be
finished
and it's what's next you gotta strike
while the Iron's hot and in that reality
sort of settling with me
what happened was the spotlight
became this thing that I had to always
chase
[Music]
I used to not have any ability to turn
off the Persona of Stevo I was just
crazy go go all the time I found that
I've become a whole lot better at
actually managing the Persona and the
career people would be uh very
disappointed to learn how boring I am in
my life I think you know come here
drakey being boring seems to suit him
well he's found his way to being
centered in his home with his various
pets
and his fiance Lux and the Comedian says
he has sobriety to thank for that this
is the beginning of your current life
sobriety is is a prerequisite for
anything positive to happen in my life
that's been proven absolutely I uh was
fundamentally incapable of having a
healthy relationship and I recognized
that and it took a lot of therapy it
took a lot of work this is where we do
the editing and the media management and
doing the work has gotten Stevo to the
best place of his life and I find that
when I'm meditating in the morning and
I'm just excited like I let that happen
man I'm going into my day I'm like I'm
ready I'm excited
and that's what makes me happy today
that's what my journey is
I like when he says there's no crazier
stunt than getting up on stage by
himself and how scary that was well
scary it always is yeah no it's funny I
was talking to Andy marlis who's a
producer but love stand up and he says
there's nothing more exhilarating than
standing up on stage delivering a comedy
routine and killing the audience right
it's just there's nothing like it's just
you out there what a journey Stevo has
had